سادت حاله من الهدوء الحذر في قطاع غزه
خلال الساعات الماضيه بعد سلسله غارات
وعمليات قصف اسرائيليه استهدفت اراضيا
زراعيه في مناطق متفرقه من القطاع وقد
استشهد فلسطينيون واصيب اربعه في احدى هذه
الغارات التي استهدفت مخيما صراط وسط
القطاع ليرتفع عدد الشهداء الى 30 والجرحى
الى اكثر من 90 وهذه هي صور تاتينا مباشره
من السحر
[موسيقى]
الدحدوح في غزه لاطلاعنا على الوضع كيف
يبدو الان هل مازال الهدوء مستمر
هذا صحيح على الاقل حتى هذه اللحظات
الهدوء الحذر الذي يشوبه كثير من التوتر
هنا في الاوساط الفلسطينيه هو سيد الموقف
على مدار الساعات القليله الماضيه وذلك لم
يسجل اي غارات اسرائيليه جديده سوى تلك
الغاره التي وقعت قبل اكثر من او زهاء
ثلاث ساعات من الان في منطقه رفح جنوبي
قطاع غزه وهي المنطقه التي تعرضت الى
سلسله من الغارات الاسرائيليه خلال هذه
الموجه من التصعيد وهذه الغاره الاخيره
كانت بالتاكيد ضد اراض زراعيه او استهدفت
اراض زراعيه كما هي الحال بالنسبه لسلسله
الغارات المكثفه والمتواصله خلال ساعات
الليل وحتى ساعات الفجر الاولى والى حد ما
ساعات الصباح الاولى وهي الغارات التي
استهدفت في مجملها مناطق زراعيه ومواقع
تتبع لفصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه
وبالتاكيد جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يتحدث
دائما عن ان هذه الاراضي التي يعود
ويستهدفها مرارا وتكرارا باعداد كبيره من
الصواريخ وبشكل متتالي وبشكل متنوع مرات
بالطائرات الحربيه المقاتله اف 16 واحيانا
بقذائف المدفعيه كل هذه الاهداف يقول جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بان المقاومه
الفلسطينيه تستخدمها في اطلاق القذائف
الصاروخيه في اطلاق الصواريخ باتجاه
الاهداف الاسرائيليه
وعمليا هذه الغارات الاسرائيليه التي كانت
مكثفه خلال ساعات الليل والفجر الاولى
كانت استهدفت هذا النوع من الاهداف وكانت
تتسم بالشده والعنف حسب شهود الاعيان وحسب
ما كنا نستمع من الاصوات الصادره عن
انفجارات الصواريخ وكورات اللهب التي
تتصاعد واعمده الدخان والغبار التي تتصاعد
منها وبالتالي كانت غارات عنيفه لكن واضح
بانها لم تكن غارات تستهدف على سبيل
المثال قيادات من الفصائل الفلسطينيه كما
جرت العاده او كما حصل يوم امس عندما
اغتالت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي قائدين
كبيرين من سرايا القدس الجناح العسكري
لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي ولذلك هذه السلسله
من الغارات استهدفت هذا النوع بشكل اساسي
من الاهداف لكنها ايضا طالت اهدافا اخرى
من قبيل تدمير منزلين الاول في منطقه دير
البلح وسط قطاع غزه وهو منزل لعائله بشير
استهدفته اولا بصواريخ من الطائرات
المسيره الاسرائيليه ومن عمدت الى تدميره
بعدد من الصواريخ التي اطلقتها المقاتلات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه منزل اخر كان هو
الاخر يعني من نصيبه التدمير في منطقه
شمال قطاع غزه على نفس الشاكله وعلى نفس
السيناريو هذه الغارات المتنوعه والمتعدده
كان نتيجتها سقوط شهيد فلسطيني بالقرب من
محطه توليد الكهرباء التي
محيطها كان مسرحا ربما لاعنف الغارات
الاسرائيليه بالمقارنه مع غيرها من
المناطق